this is crazy how do i get there that's
impossible
london just falling down
this part of them is not going to work i
just don't sense it
my name's samuel leeds i'm a property
investor i don't own any houses in
london all of my houses are outside of
london and everyone tells me that london
is really hard it's impossible to make
money in london
starting with no money so we literally
just my laptop
laptop bag no money just basic
essentials for travel and things like
that
i'm gonna see if i can secure a no money
down
property deal so let's see what we can
do in london with no money without any
knowledge of the area
let's go this is absolutely insane just
leaving now like okay let's go but we
haven't actually got anywhere to go to
i think the first thing is i think to
find
like an estate agent if i don't excuse
me
do you know if there's estate agents
around here like people that sell
so literally that's how from scratch
this is it's a case of
where's the nearest estate agency i'm
just gonna go in i'm not gonna try and
get a deal
i'm just gonna try and get an idea of
the market i'm just gonna try and get an
idea of
how much properties are going for i
don't know the market at all here
so the only thing i know about london i
keep an eye on london house prices
because i know that everywhere follows
london we might have to secret film
i mean i imagine in london they'll be
okay with filming but let's see
oh my goodness look at this i just put
estate agents
all these estate agents a state agent at
a stage in the state agency all these
are
established in the area i might bring
the agents
and get a feel for who's friendly
because there's so many there's so many
to choose from
there's literally hundreds of estate
agents
hey ben my name's samuel uh just a quick
call um
i've actually just moved to london i'm a
property investor
and i don't know if it's possible if i
could pop into the office at some point
and just have like a 15 minute 10 15
minute chat with someone just about
just to get some advice on on where the
best areas are to buy to
to rent um i just have to get a bit of
guidance really just because
no problem all right for today i'm free
for that couple of hours so i can even
pop in now if you fray i mean if you
want to do that yeah that's cool
because actually i'm just in between
things so i haven't got a meeting
remember we can just sit by my desk yeah
ben that sounds great i'll see in a few
minutes
that's how easy it is to get like a
state agent
to meet with you he was friendly that
was great let's go and see what we can
do there's so many ways
ways to make money in property
whether it's to buy a property below
market value and then sell it
whether it's to rent something and then
add value and
re-rent it out called rent to rent and
take the monthly cash flow from it buy a
house and pay for it later like a
delayed sale and then in the meantime
you make money from it and you wait for
the property to rise or a lease option
agreement
flipping properties packaging and
selling properties i've got to be
creative because i'm doing this whole
challenge with
no money what i really want to do now is
i just want to brainstorm the area
within the m25
what's going on what's the market doing
and what the agents are saying
i'll be able to assess which strategy i
can apply to that to make money starting
with no money
in london he'll get really uncomfortable
when he hears there's a camera but i
want to film as much of this as possible
to show you guys
hey how you doing i think we just spoke
on the phone great to see you i'm samuel
i'm just trying to work out is london a
good area to buy
is it is it not what the best things
would be to buy and things like that we
only did the west end
so what kind of areas would west end
what kind of things
if i had a good broker and say like
250 000 pounds and i just wanted to see
a good steady return
unfortunately not even with a mortgage
no
really 250 total no 250 cash yeah
and then a mortgage yeah so you're
probably i mean the entry price i've got
something at uh
400. 400 in total is that what it is so
covent garden west west end london area
you're looking around about 400
absolute minimum purchase price yeah and
that would be for like an apartment
would it
be from apartment yeah you won't miss by
you won't raise money houses
sorry because they're not there because
they're too expensive
thanks so much for your time cheers mate
so that went pretty terribly basically
initially i was thinking maybe rent to
rent
but when i walked in they were just
really kind of cold
and i just thought okay trying to
persuade this guy and talk to him about
the idea of doing a rent to rent
or a lease option or something really
creative is really probably not going to
happen
so i shifted strategy let's assume i had
money what would be the best thing to
invest in
and i thought if i can find a really
good investment then even if i haven't
got the money i can either find the
money
or i can take that investment and then i
can pass it on to somebody and charge a
broker fee
so i just started saying okay well
what's the best kind of investments
you know can you buy a house add value
to it and refinance it
can you buy a property and get and it
was just no no
no no that doesn't work in london
i think i'm really gonna struggle
actually i was really excited up until
about
10 minutes ago now i'm thinking i'm
thinking this is going to be just a
nightmare
i'm just going to another agent and just
see if they say the same thing and if
they do and if it's just like no no no
then i need to just move out of merely
bones and when i asked him i said to him
are you familiar like guaranteed rents
or anything he was just like
completely blank let's call some more
agents
what i'm going to do now i'm going to
just see if i can get some good property
investments
if i go too complicated they're just
going to put the phone down on me i
think maybe
maybe they won't hello my name's samuel
um just a quick call
i'm i'm new to the area i'm actually in
um in marleybone i'm looking to invest
into uh into the local property market
and i'm looking for something that i can
develop i'm looking to buy a property
that i can just add value to
um with a view to them refinancing all
right that's perfect
no worries i'll call them back
why not leave a message so they can get
back oh geez
all right i'll call another agent
welcome to the ee
nope i'm just gonna ring and see if
people will accept guaranteed rent
or if they do hmos i don't think you can
do service accommodation in the center
of london there's a rule around that
this part of london's not going to work
i just don't sense it it's so expensive
he laughed at me when i said i had a
million pounds
he's like a million pounds
[Laughter]
where would work in london now where's
cheaper here she is
hello hello hi hi someone sorry i
apologize i believe the line got cut off
let me uh
find some properties i'll go through a
property search quickly today
and i'll send you over before the end of
the day amazing thank you so much
thank you have a good day i don't think
we're going to have much joy here
it's about finding the right agent i
really believe that when you find the
right agent or find the right investors
it happens but i'm starting from scratch
i like to buy low rent high and in
london
nothing is low so it's a case of maybe
buy high
and rent really high or buy but pay
later and when i like
i need to change my model a little bit
here i think if i can't get my hands on
a million
pounds in this city then i suck
because oh i'm so sorry man
i definitely suck i'm gonna find some
landlords find some agents
and i'm planning to try and book some
same-day appointments because time is
money
in a country or a city where there's a
lot of money there's just no reason why
you can't make money
if i go to a right move let's find the
cheapest houses don't show
shared ownership don't show new home
don't show retirement home
okay so the cheapest house is 130 000
pounds and
it's a boat
two bed flat 170 grand
they're just so expensive even in
stratford
so what i might try and do is ring up
and just see how much rent you'd get for
that and work out what the return on
investment
is on a house in london so this looks
decent it's a nice little apartment
three bed it's on for 205 grand
it's been on the market a few quite a
few months
first floor flat they've already had an
offer
for 185 maybe that won't be any good i'm
gonna ring them anyway
and just see what's going on it's never
about the house it's always about the
agent it's all about the relationship
you know what i do feel much better now
now i've got my own little office
i'm on right move which is like my home
the houses are a bit more realistic i
feel better
hey buddy just a quick call i'm ringing
about the property it's on for 205. i
believe you've had an
offer for 185 already correct yeah
what's the situation then is it like
if someone offers more than 185 is it is
it still on the market or is it is it
now off the market yeah it stays on the
market
until uh until we exchange the contract
basically if i was to see it view it
like it and offer more than 105 then so
is it just a case of who offers the
highest bid is that how it works
do you know what the rent would be if i
was to rent this out do you know what
sort of rent you'd get
thank you so much for your help bye now
but what he did say that was really
interesting
was that hmos worked really well in
i think he said what did he i think he
said the area's newer the only problem
is
you need to get a license and apparently
getting a license in newham
is a nightmare but hms do work really
well
so what we could do is we could find
hmos
that are existing hmos in newark with a
landlord who's tired or
lives far away or whatever and have an
option to buy on it or do a rent to rent
so let me find on spare room existing
hmos
this could work it's just market
research man to begin with
what are the rich property investors the
smart people what are they doing in
london that's what i need to figure out
maybe i need to phone some investors
find some like investor networks
going on the tube is going to be so
weird probably so busy when it's like
it's not even rush hour
seems like in london every hour is rush
hour
i think we're gonna absolutely kill it
in stratford finding like a little base
like going into a little coffee shop and
then just getting loads of leads
like estate agents leads find investors
go on gumtree spare room
get lots of people call lots of people
and then get all the hot people all the
interested people and then just book out
appointments
so noisy with like street preachers and
people walking
let's find somewhere quiet and uh start
making the calls
hey man how you doing bro i started
following you oh nice one
about two months ago oh good for you bro
it's really nice to have you and your
wife you're looking at yeah yeah yeah
no we're renting that place yeah we i
believe rent rent where you live and
then own what you rent
mate thank you you're welcome man cheers
definitely thank you bro thanks i feel
like i'm in a different country
like this is so different
looks like we've got our own office here
people say i've not got an office at
home you don't need an office
you just walk into a travel lodge baby
this is when magic's gonna happen now
i'm gonna have to ring some agents and
act like i'm buying a hmo
and then you get a feel for what the hmo
market's like there's lots of live-in
landlords
i might just text these living or live
out landlords
and say would you be open to a
guaranteed rent
or potentially selling your house i'll
send that to all the landlords and all
the agents i'll phone them
and get a feel for what the area is like
and what the rents are like and stuff
like that and then together
i should be getting my market research
while also putting out my marketing
messages so here's the message i'm gonna
write i'm gonna say
so hey i've just seen your property on
spare room would you be interested in
receiving a fixed guaranteed rent
or maybe selling your property all
together if so please text back and
let's jump on a quick call
samuel boom so that is my message
all right this guy's a landlord so i'm
going to text him the usual spiel
hello my name's samuel i'm just ringing
about the ad on spare room
uh that you've got the house for renting
stratford so we're taking viewings on
that when are you available
well i'm actually in the area today i
don't know if that's uh
if it's possible i can look this
afternoon
okay we do need to find out
how much rent because we could rent that
for two grand a month but then
rent the rooms out for 500 pound a month
and we've got no profit
i don't know if the maths are even
stacking up here at the minute all i
know is
we're meeting people who are open to the
idea of doing rental rent all right
see what else we got some of these rooms
are asking like
800 pound a month for a room look at
this
that's renting for 500 pounds a month
how would anyone rent that for 500 pound
there's no floor space
i want to find out what the best areas
are for the hmos
are you a management company that rents
out hmos in rooms
you should too how does it work then
what kind of fees do you charge
which could you handle all the headache
yeah thank you
i look forward to seeing you i hope to
do business i'll be in about 2 30.
what they're doing is rent to rent
they're giving a guaranteed rent to
landlords in the new area
which is competition for me but the fact
that there's competition
means that it works because there's
companies paying staff and paying for
offices
doing that exact model all i need is one
or two of those someone's already
messaged me
back hello what kind of services are you
interested in i'm getting leads now
i think i i i feel something bubbling
so we're filling the diary up now so
we've got 2 30 me with an estate agents
talk about the area we've got a
3 30 meeting with a guy who's got a
property which we could take over on a
rent around it might be
by the end of the day we literally have
a rent event we've got landlords
messaging back
saying what kind of services are you
interested in we know the area works
because other people
there's companies in the area doing rent
events so if renter ain't works
we just need to find a landlord
motivated enough to want to pass his
whole house over to us
see anyone could do this though couldn't
they it's not complicated
it's just doing it my name's samuel and
i'm basically just looking to take a
whole property where i can just rent the
rooms out to my staff
all right i'll speak to you soon thank
you cool that's a possibility that's an
agent who's renting out a house
all the rooms are available it's just
from new today how's about how about i
just say
i'll rent all the rooms off yeah so your
landlord's going to be really happy
because all the rooms are gone
but i want a discount get a discount
then i rent the rooms could work right i
just need to have more viewings
and i need to use the rent to rent
company to do the due diligence on the
houses
which they'll do for me although they
didn't sound that friendly did i he
really didn't
but i'm sure i'll charm him when we get
there i definitely feel that we can get
a rent to rent in
in um stratford area i definitely feel
we can do that
i guess it's just a case of do we leave
it there do we just get a rent around do
we then keep going
how do we pay for the rent to rent are
we gonna get multiple wins events could
that be the strategy that could be good
it's quite high risk though because we
don't know if it's going to work so if
we just suddenly take on all these rents
events
what happens if we don't rent them out
as easy as we thought and then suddenly
we've got all this debt each month doing
a rent to rent without
due diligence is risky because then
you've got to pay guaranteed rent to
someone
and you might break even
or not even make any money at all like
who knows which is why we're doing our
research
hey man i'm great thanks for coming out
so quick so we're new to the beautiful
city of stratfor
it seems like a pretty good area where
we're looking to buy some houses around
here i've just had a message
from spare room hey samuel that's great
5 pm tonight is perfect boom
you'll be the first to view before an
evening of viewings
that's great so that means that we've
got multiple views now if i was to buy
property here
maybe for 500 000 700 000 something like
that
with five or six bedrooms and then you
guys could just
manage it rent it out i'd love to see
what my what my return on investment
would be on that
i'll show you a couple of properties and
see what you think all right so this guy
i'm actually meeting him later
so he's got a property but it's a um
it's a six bed house
i think he'd just be very happy with the
guaranteed rent
and how does that does that rent out
well does that work well as a hmo that
it does it does it's a good return on
the properties and the price is implies
to especially
for a guaranteed rent for him like how
much would you guys
be prepared to give him on a guaranteed
rent six double bedrooms
new much you can make bui
as a landlord as all doubles there will
be ranging between 550
to 750 for the couple the minimum you'll
get is 3500
is the minimum your guy yeah that's
roughly the minimum you'll get but then
you'll have to pay the utility bills
because it's html
so you take off about 300 pounds because
your duty bids so he's asking for three
six he's gonna be too tight isn't it
anyway 550 for us
for a single double run one person 750
for a couple
is kind of minimum yeah run-of-the-mill
is it achievable
i'll show you my other one as well this
one's less 2150 is the asking price
and it's got four bedrooms it is a
silver even for family
you don't have to go to atmo in that
area you can
get that price yeah he'll rent that out
of that price
yeah yeah it's not as normal which one
do you prefer do you prefer that one the
four bed or the six bed
on the price that one is better yeah and
the quality of the
property the six bedroom is better
awesome
thank you so much thank you appreciate
your time thanks jay cheers man
good luck they were so helpful it's
amazing
what people will say when you just ask
the questions
two viewings that i've got lined up this
evening they're both are good
the six bed is better i think it's just
a case of going and viewing them now
and putting an offer forward that was
brilliant brilliant man
city move you're the best all right
let's go view some houses
i feel so confident now because before i
was just thinking
i don't know this area from adam i don't
know
what i'm gonna say i don't know what i'm
gonna offer i don't know anything but
now i feel
like confident i know the area
how you doing bro you know what i'll
watch a video last year yeah yeah i
flipped a couple of uh
properties during uh you know the busy
period yeah yeah 2018. yeah
and i just found you today bro that's
awesome so what you think you watch my
videos flipped a couple properties made
a lot of money
one of my mates he he does uh lettings
as well for someone else yeah so he kind
of helped me out
and we made about eight thousand for
that one nice man yeah
nice to get back into it man yeah yeah
if you should be leaving around because
i've been working on this shot come on
tag me on facebook
thank you for that you're welcome bro
see you later thank you so much my
friend
have a wonderful day hi yeah we're uh
meeting lee yeah yeah hi hey how you
doing mate
good to see you so glad that we're here
and not in marleybone it's a different
vibe
and it's a different market but we're
still in proper london aren't we
oh yeah
yeah it's very nice isn't it yeah
so here because they got yeah
this
three doubles up here and then one
double downstairs
what do you think that would rent out by
the room for i mean an average double
room in this area is about
five seven five to six fifty if you're
doing well
we've got a viewing after this on a on a
six bed
yeah he's wanting a 3k it's on for 3-6
but he says he's open probably accept
around about 3k
i think we're going to get a deal with
these guys so i mean my plan would be to
take one or two properties to start with
and then if if they're not that
profitable well i guess i've learned a
lesson
if they are profitable and it works and
the setup is smooth to then slowly
replicate what i've done in birmingham
and just slowly build
you know maybe get 50 units so this
problem we looked at do you think that
that could work then did you but i'll
have a chat with him
yeah and then i'll come back to you and
if it doesn't
by the sounds of it there could be
others but there will be others
how likely would it be that another one
would come up in the next you know
however long
it could be a couple of weeks it could
be a couple of months you really just
don't know you've just missed about
three or four oh wow the last couple of
weeks
of all the suburbs they pay us a rolling
50 pound a month that's great
50 pound a month yeah awesome thanks so
much thank you thanks
that was good he's
gonna find a surrender rent it might not
be that house that we just viewed
but even if it's not he's gonna fight
he's got deals coming up
likes us trusts us i'm over the moon
we've got another house to see and oh my
goodness 20
minutes let's get another uber we
haven't eaten today but it's all good
i'm just hungry for success man flats
and houses oh there's another agent
there's just loads man
the thing is right you don't need more
than one or two good agents
we've got an agent now we just need to
start seeing some landlords i can't
believe i just got a rent to rent
through an agent
and all he wants is 50 quid a month 50
quid a month
all right i called an uber hello mate
samuel right
that's me how's it going it's going
really well my friend
right we've basically uh come to london
with no money or trying to
buy a house with no money that's
impossible
well we're believers man just on time 5
p.m i'm gonna give that oba driver like
a hundred pound tip
let me just have a look at the house so
i can i just before you ever go into a
viewing you need to be familiar
[Music]
cool cheers love property license oh
that's good
i think when we've been um looking at
the pictures and stuff and showing other
estate agents
the property you don't quite realize how
big and
spacious and clean and everything is do
you really cause yeah we've been we've
been looking at the pictures of this
house
just this afternoon and uh it's actually
better i think in real life then yeah
there are
speakers then it looks yeah they're not
great are they so how much
how much rent do you reckon someone pay
for this room because there's not like
an ensuite or anything
is there
yeah we've been we've spent the day kind
of talking with hm management companies
and just kind of getting an idea on
prices
what they think they were saying sort of
between 550 and 750
look at this man the views are
pretty good man
you wouldn't want to fall
[Music]
okay yeah it's really really pleasant
it's nicer than the last one pub we just
saw would you reckon
yeah i can tell straight away from
meeting you that you're just a
businessman
i mean i i only buy properties which i
would
that's that's a big rule for me so if we
were to basically give you a guaranteed
rent
and and manage ourselves what would be
like the lowest that you would be able
to accept and still be happy
i think 3000 would be yeah 3 000.
that would
the only thing is with that would be if
we were paying all the council tax and
stuff
which would probably i don't know let's
call it 400.
excluding the rent the total would be
2.9 expenses
but yeah so that's how much in a map
24 200 150 that sounds a bit like 250
pound a month
for the expenses i think so i didn't
include wi-fi
and tv license yeah even so it seems a
bit there because if we
rented it out for say
600 a room now you get more than that
600
before the two smaller ones okay let's
even let's just call it 650 for all of
the rooms
times by six that's 3 900. so that gives
us 900
to pay management get it
you see what i'm saying if you're saying
you want council types gas station all
the utility bills
plus our management because then when
you've got voids
having to come out deal with tenants
it's gonna probably leave us in
in the minuses you've been managers
or we manage ourselves so it's either a
case of paying someone or
having just a lot of time and time is
money
so it's kind of the same story so i
think to make it to make it work it
would need to be probably more like two
and a half thousand
to then give us 500 a month profit but
if we gave you two five
some of my properties i've got one
guaranteed rent you'll always get less
when it's guaranteed just because you've
got no
voids no maintenance management fees
i say you've got viewings this evening
on this house
so i would be thinking around two five
or maybe
if we did a bit more like two seven
fifth day
but then you pay the bills okay
i like you i'm a very good negotiator so
because because i was trying to work it
out then
i was thinking 3000 and you do
everything license furnishing and
everything
but we wouldn't make profit on that what
would be
better for you 2-5 with
we paying the bills or two seven fifteen
you pay the bills i'm not saying either
would but which ones would be more
attractive
i think most attractive for me is to
have nothing to do with so not pay the
bills or anything
would 2-5 i mean is that is that is that
even workable
see how the guys get on tonight and then
we can then maybe once we've seen the
tenants we can have a chat
and and see if we can work something out
that's an okay great well thank you so
much for showing us around i'll see you
in an hour and 15 minutes
and i'll speak to you before sounds very
good thanks man i appreciate your time
ivan
well that was pretty interesting wasn't
it that deal if we pay him
2500 we will be able to rent that place
out for about 3
900 which will leave us with 1400 pounds
with that 1400 pounds we can pay the
bills
and the rest is profit
there's no gas the water's free
to be honest i almost feel like i'm in a
dreamland i don't even know what day it
is
i feel like i need to process what's
going on we've got agents
that are giving this deal we've got
investors that are giving us deals it
almost seems too good to be true i never
thought that i'd hear myself say that
but it's just insane isn't it
oh about the an agent i've had to email
some
emails from the agents as well here are
some properties for sale again man just
it's like a snowball that's the thing
when you when you stop putting yourself
out there and putting offers forward and
calling agents
they then come to you and it's only a
matter of time when even if you stop
and retire you've still got people
constantly coming to you with deals and
opportunities and offers
and it just snowballs success just
snowballs i reckon we should stand
outside because he'll be here hey how
you doing
how are you good man good to meet you
i'm samuel
[Music]
how are you doing come on bro so
basically the property
it's just brand new it all refurbished
recently yes
nice fridge freezer quite a decent
amount of
um you know work stops you've got all
the things washer just a little bit of
storage in here
the six rooms and the price is 650
pounds a month
and the higher you go the better and
more expensive they get
you know what i'm saying like wow if it
were me
i'd be going for this room even though
it's not the biggest it's just i love
the balcony
listen dude 2500 i will take this on
manage it i know you could get more but
no headache
would you like to do the contract serve
tomorrow would you finish it no
or we could do 3 000 and you can pay all
the bills that's slightly better
for you that's actually a message from
you so how about you
furniture would you finish it then i
think yeah okay i'll photoshoot
you can you pay me could you do business
i'll send you over a contract tomorrow
all right i'm testing we'll hit the road
thank you so much hey quest i think we
need something why would you give
away thousand one hundred pounds
to me and and not and not just rent it
out fully and manage it yourself
i'll have guaranteed rent i won't have
to think about this
and i can i can focus on other projects
which which i've got on at the moment
so this will this will um be less of an
earner for me but it will be it will
give me more peace of mind
yeah that makes sense and then for me
it's a thousand pound a month
and i'll have put down nothing because
you're furnishing it
you're not charging me any upfront rent
so
why not i will pay a month up front rent
but i'll use these guys money to do that
it's basically no money down from my
perspective
[Music]
so we've got the keys thank you so much
lovely meeting you thank you for the
lift back
let's go man dude this day
so woke up this morning no idea of how
to invest in london or what strategy
and this evening
i've got the keys to a renter end
property that's going to make me a grand
a month a thousand pound a month i'm
going to be doing in the next
week or so a q a answering all of your
questions around
exactly what happened what's going on
with the property how i did what i did
if you've got any questions around
property
or rent to rent or what i did on this
video comment your questions below
and i will come back and answer all of
your questions on another video
separately
so comment below also please do
subscribe to the channel
turn the notification bell on if you'd
like to watch more i did do a very
interesting challenge similar to this
one where i spent a whole week
trying to become financially free from
scratch if you haven't seen that
you can check that out right here also
if you'd like to learn the skills and
you'd like to become a property investor
regardless of how much money you've got
right now you can learn exactly how to
do the same
why don't you comment down to the
property investors crash course i'll put
a ticket on the house completely free
just find out more right here and of
course don't forget to subscribe
over here as well thanks so much i'll
see you next week subscribe